[Music]
[Applause]
hi everybody my name is mark barnard
this is the inaugural episode of black
man beyond we are scum and villainy can
t know that the people at home know
where you are so this is all weird Kevin
Aziz want to do was in Vancouver
directing episode of Supergirl so I
decided why not get together on a
Tuesday night in October oh you're
welcome
it's like my Fresh Air Fund for nerds
but inside instead of outside because
nobody needs the [ __ ] Sun so yeah
we're gonna talk today almost
exclusively about Castle Rock castle but
first I gotta talk about this [ __ ]
thing look at that have you seen this
this this is gonna be my like portrait
of Dorian Gray that I keep in the closet
so I can kill people and never get older
mate thank you very much for putting
this together you're awesome awesome
dude
so the way this night is gonna work is
I'm gonna talk a little bit about how I
got to Castle Rock then the great end
Mundy Roth cornet from screen junkies as
you come up here and talk to me about
Castle Rock and then you guys get a
chance to talk about Castle Rock whether
I'm here or not but I'm here so ask a
question or two so yeah
I'm gonna tell you how I got to Castle
Rock I worked for Entertainment Weekly
from 1996 to 2009 and when I was there
for about a year and a half I had an
assistant guys name was Scott Brown he
was the worst assistant I've ever had
like he could not keep it calendar he
had no idea what to do with receipts he
had no idea how to like transfer a phone
call like all of the things one would
use to measure an assistant he
failed miserably at the one thing he was
really good I was writing and it was
abundantly clear that you know he was
going to be a [ __ ] rock star and my
time there would be commemorated by oh
he hired Scott Brown once so because
Scott Brown then went to be the theater
critic at New York Magazine he then went
to be a staff writer on Manhattan from
there he went to be a staff writer on
sharp objects and now he's writing or
has written the book for the Broadway
musical beetlejuice I know right a
[ __ ] dude who answered my phone's is
now gonna win a Tony in like two years
he also went to Harvard which tickled me
to no end because I went to like a
Community College in New York and I was
like I hired a Harvard boy lovely young
white boy answered my phones he went to
Harvard you know particularly [ __ ] out
of me but he's an awesome guy and and if
you're a writer part of the the way you
get better as a writer is by getting a
group of people you can trust to be your
first readers right it's like I wrote a
draft of a thing I need to have somebody
who I can trust read it and give me some
notes on it and Scott was one of those
guys for me like really early on I would
write pilots I would write movies or
whatever I [ __ ] Road I would slip a
draft of Scott and say hey how do I make
this better and he would tell me and and
flash-forward like you know he left in
2006 and I left DW 2009 flash forward to
the winter of 2016 where he we had still
had that relationship he'd write a thing
and send it to me I'd write some of the
Senate to him he was then he calls me
he's like hey so what's your latest
script it's like you've read it you know
what it is he's like he's in a good
shape like you read it you know where it
is and he said send it to me because I'm
working on this show the guys who did
Manhattan the Sam Sean dusty Thomason
are putting together a Stephen King show
and they desperately desperately need in
there
and they don't know any nerds like these
are dudes who like went to Harvard and
do to enter like the Iowa Writers
Workshop and dudes who like all about
short stories and did not really know
what to do with Stephen King with genre
with horror
they knew character and plot and and
phim and all of that [ __ ] but they
needed somebody who could tell them hey
you know what needs to happen here you
need to kill some other [ __ ]
maybe we don't not kill some of the
[ __ ] in this show about horror and so
so Scott took my latest pilot script he
slipped it to them I suppose like
November of 2016 and I hear nothing
which is par for the course in Hollywood
but also [ __ ] petrifying when you do
they like oh here's the thing I'm most
proudest of take a look at it maybe let
me know what you think and then when
they don't like I guess I'll just keep
pretending to be a writer I suppose but
then I got a call in in December just
before Christmas saying hey can you be a
bad robot two o'clock this afternoon and
I said yes and then I went to my boss as
I was working the LA Times at the time
and said I have a dentist's appointment
tomorrow at 2:00 p.m. and I'm kind of
gonna be gone all day because it's
[ __ ] dentist so don't look for me
before the next day and so I go to bed
robot which if you've ever get the
chance to go to bed robot egg you should
totally go be it is not called bad robot
outside the building it is called the
National typewriter company
and it's on I know it's on Olympic
Boulevard in Santa Monica I don't if
I'll tell you where it is
they have they have so much [ __ ]
security it doesn't matter that you know
where it is like I want to see JJ's
fries ed-209 is on the front lawns
register your offense and so I got on
there and I'm sitting in the waiting
room and playing with all the [ __ ]
toys and because the the waiting room is
life a rotating gallery of [ __ ] JJ
happens to like or loved when he was a
child so it's like Barbie though there
was an Ava Duvernay Barbie doll there
was a bunch of like old robots there was
phaser from Star Trek just it's [ __ ]
bananas and that's this dude's office is
like the best museum you've ever been in
and so I'm sitting in there and I'm
[ __ ] twiddling my heels waiting to
see if JG it passes behind Oh [ __ ] JJ
and then I get called it as conference
room and inside dusty and Sam the two
guys were running the show they pretend
like they can't tell me what it is right
because it's bad robot and all this
[ __ ] high security it's like so we're
working on a show we can't say what it's
about but how do you feel about horror I
was like I love it
I'm also a giant [ __ ] [ __ ] because I
kinda hate it also like my love of
horror kind of stopped around the Dawn
of the Dead remake I think I was kind of
on board before then like I grew up in
the 70s and 80s oh it's all about John
Carpenter all about Sam Raimi all about
the kind of like awesome VHS har that
you could get as a kid when it was kind
of like crafts and a little bit of [ __ ]
and I'll put in a [ __ ] blender and
you loved it to death right I was not
here for like Kay horror or J horror or
like like [ __ ] Eli Roth torture porn
like I just was never my jam like I I
like being manipulated into an emotion
that I find pleasurable and being
terrified is not an emotion that I get a
lot of joy out of so I was not that guy
but I said well yeah you know I loved
horror as a kid and I loved reading
horror I loved watching horror to a
point I also happen to be a pretty big
Stephen King fan because they don't know
that I knew that it was a Stephen King
show it was still like [ __ ] secrecy
and I was like yeah you know I read a
lot of Stephen King as a kid but never
like the super scary stuff but I went
like the Bachman books I went The
Shining
I went The Stand I went you know the
running man I went all of that like eyes
of the Dragon like the weird esoteric
Stephen King [ __ ] you know like well
we're doing this show it's about a black
lawyer in an all-white town said really
tell me more
white guys about your conception of an
all-white town with a black lawyer in it
you know I said well I have no
experience I've been snowmobiling which
I have wasn't lying although I'm totally
fine lying about [ __ ] in a meeting cuz
they're never gonna check like nobody
checks references right I mean I don't
do you guys check references like do you
know how I got here
but he try and bother to verify my bona
fides we I went snowmobiling got a buddy
who loves to snowmobile he would always
love to go in like Vermont in New
Hampshire and Maine and so I would go
because I like speed you don't have to
really physically exert yourself you're
sitting on a [ __ ] snowmobile and you
could pretend to be athletic and but
snowmobiling in February in Maine is the
widest thing ever in every regard like
it's covered in snow like everything the
roads you can't even [ __ ] see your
deep [ __ ] forest and every place you
go you're just surrounded by like the
salt of the earth is I suppose the nice
way of referring to the denizens of
Maine in February which were all super
lovely people but there was definitely a
sense of being the only one in a place
you know but I I've been to Romania
again and I would count on try and count
how many african-americans I would see
and I never spun another one I found a
bunch of like like Liberians and
Nigerians and like I found black people
from Africa yeah like you know Romania
and apparently Rainey has pretty decent
school system I would say you guys a
little bar Romania Romania I'm not gonna
tell you bout Romania there's a [ __ ]
about Romania but it was a place that I
went where I never saw anybody who was
me and and all of that started to talk
to the show they were trying to build
they were trying to build a show about a
town that the world had left behind that
that had been rained upon with so much
horror that people just fled to the
hills and who stays in a town like that
who hangs out in Castle Rock after
everybody [ __ ] left and and what does
that feel like and I said well I also
had lived in New Jersey in Middletown
Jerzy and post 9/11 it had the highest
loss rate or their per capita more
people died from that particular town in
911 than any other place in the country
and and and the town felt like there was
a scar like a bleeding wound in that
town because everybody knew somebody who
didn't come home that day everybody knew
somebody who hadn't made it and that
level of trauma and that level of horror
and that level of dis existential dread
was real for like three or four years
after 9/11 and so you know I gave my
[ __ ] peter-patter and I get that dual
tap dancer the room and here's where you
should hire me because I'm awesome and
they said great awesome do you come
highly recommended we'll call you and
then I left and I called my agent says I
think I didn't get this job because I
did all my [ __ ] I was as cute as I
could be and I got [ __ ] nothing and
so I went back to [ __ ] work and you
know Danny yeah no [ __ ] editing
stories and then February 10th I get a
call of 2017 saying hey we're starting
the writers room in four days can you be
there and I said yes and then I went to
my boss and I was like hey guess what I
don't have a dentist appointment but I'm
quitting kind of like today so I know
you'd really like two weeks notice I
know you'd even like 48 hours notice but
I was gonna say it's Wednesday and I'm
not gonna be here on Monday I hope
you're good with this like what's the
job as well I'm gonna be I can't tell
you because I'm I'm sworn to [ __ ]
secrecy I can say this for a TV show
I cannot say who's producing it I cannot
say what it's about
but they're like you can't just [ __ ]
quit and not tell us anything that's
what I tell my boss right this is just
between you and me the show called
Castle Rock Stephen King and J James
producing it and so my boss then sends
out the Marquis leaving email and
broadcasts all of that [ __ ]
to like 300 people in the entertainment
department of the LA Times all of which
have like Twitter accounts and [ __ ] I'm
like I'm like you can't just okay I [ __ ]
now I'm totally leaving because you just
did that I was gonna be nice and give
you some phone numbers of people you
could call maybe replace me [ __ ] that
I'm gone and so I showed up for work day
one and you know it's it's a little
weird because the TV show it's it's it's
transitory like you're it's all
freelance nobody really ever counts on
having a job for longer than a year
maybe two years if you're on a [ __ ]
hit show maybe we'll go three years but
just it's a journey it's all a [ __ ]
churn and so every day a bit like day
one of a writers room is like first day
of school right like you just show up
you like I hope the kids like me what
should i what should I [ __ ] where's I
don't know I'm 46 years old I don't give
a [ __ ] if they like me I have children
and a mortgage I don't give a [ __ ] but
just like hi Who am I gonna sit with at
lunch do I eat in my office do we get
out here are we gonna go for a walk
where are you from what it's it's weird
like first date / first day of
kindergarten
/ we're also getting to play in Stephen
King world and you know I'm gonna talk
with Roth Cornett in a second and she's
gonna she's is a super die-hard fan of
the show and she's an amazing journalist
and so and she has feelings and thoughts
and theories about the show and and I'm
gonna let her just unload with both
barrels but we it was a it was a
ridiculous opportunity to be able to
take Stephen King and do not a cover
song of Stephen King like we didn't want
to do an adaptation of any one
particular story but it was can we can
we find the lost Stephen King song the
Stephen King song that feels like every
other Stephen King song that feels as if
it's a thing that that dude wrote and
feels I got slots on the shelf with
every other Stephen King book that
you've ever that you've ever read and if
we can pull that off people will I think
respond to it and my job was to make
sure that it was actually a horror show
and hopefully we we succeeded in some
level or another
so that is my path to castle rock that
is how I got there that is that is how I
set the GPS to take me to [ __ ] Maine
and and help scare people and let's
bring up or off and Rafa is going to
grill the [ __ ] out of me about things I
probably shouldn't tell anybody else if
I'd ever like to work in Castle Rock
again so I sat down to jot down a few
notes for tonight about Katherine and I
have the beginnings of a very weird
dissertation oh well by all means get
after it is this like a moral relativism
kind of a bar or do we want to just do
Easter eggs okay okay it's Tuesday so
we're gonna do full spoilers yeah yes
everything I'm assuming you all here
have seen the show yes okay and if you
haven't seen the show at home
and shyam it like feel free to yell if
you want me to hit a particular note
like how much should we all be reading
The Dark Tower before season two on a
scale of 1 to read the entire thing
today um from what I know about what
season 2 is gonna be you will not have
to read the entirety of The Dark Tower
you will not have to read really any of
the Dark Tower
okay I mean it couldn't hurt well that's
gonna get to some of the theories that I
have seen going on and that I have in my
own I have a lot of feelings about this
show but let's just start with the idea
that I feel like there's all these
themes right but for me the biggest one
was just that the opposite of fate is
doubt right the opposite of faith is
death this is so weird to do with a
microphone
in a bar feels like the right place
though like maybe we need like drinks
can we do a little Ken can we can I fix
you a drink we have I'm sure would be
happy to give us something what do you
want any beer that you have like beer I
do light here dark beer German beer
American beer I like beer I like to
drink beer yeah boys like beer girls
like beer this crowd likes beer I just
thought Venom I think I deserve a beer
oh oh no you did it was bad you just say
you need to bury some brain cells after
saying it is a lovely story of a boy in
his symbiote if transformers can be
about a boy in his car then why can't
venom be about a boy in his alien bodies
pet let's talk about Andre Harlan a
little bit Andre Colin yes yeah right
yeah unbelievable and what's amazing to
me about his performance and his thank
you so much I wonder what it is his
character arc is that he starts is like
the most relatable right it's just kind
of the most cynical he's the least
attached to the world he was never it
the actor was never in any of the movies
and by the end it comes full circle and
he is Castle Rock and these things that
have defined him in terms of being
employing doubt for the greater good
becomes a very sinister version of doubt
he's sitting there in the same doubt
that that the warden was in at the
beginning of the show by the way is the
warden like not the defense against the
dark arts position on this show like
like you're definitely gonna die well
there was there was early on there was
there was a lot of talk in the room
about the Goodman
Castlerock this idea that and it parts
of it still remain in the show
especially when it gets episode 9 I
think it is but the idea that that
warden Lacey the sheriff Pangborn and
that Reverend Deaver were like the three
pillars of Castle Rock and they would
shoulder the burden of having to do the
wrong thing for the right reason and and
the wrong thing clearly is putting a kid
in a [ __ ] cage but is it that's the
moral question of the show there's also
I want to say it's in Octavia Butler's
short story or Ursula K Le Guin I was
yeah but it's I think it's called but
it's about a it's a reality that decides
that they want to keep a boy underground
in prison and if he's in prison the town
above will be blissfully free of
anything horrible but they have to
swallow upon themselves the moral weight
of doing an awful thing to an innocent
child because it makes it everything
better for everybody it's the lottery
ultimate sure underground but with boys
and not girls and so that idea of this
is a this is on the face of it a bad
thing because if you have no evidence
that this kid is doing anything bad or
you've see him do anything bad but you
believe as Matthew Deaver did that he is
the cause of all the evil in Castle Rock
then that kid has to be in jail okay and
and who is willing to make that call and
what's the price of that call once you
make it sure but and it is look we start
out with this idea of that if you have
any measure of reasonable doubt you
cannot kill a person but is it worse to
do that then leave them sitting rotting
in a jail for 27 years by themselves in
solitary confinement like in that case
once you've done that you've potentially
made a monster if he wasn't a monster to
begin with there's so much revelations
in this and then he fully is like came
once as the the lamb and then
the lion is that am I getting that right
I don't know my Bible Bible people know
so much yeah I mean it's it's it's also
the idea that that the kid was we had
talked so much in the room about a what
the kid was what the prisoner was is he
is he the devil is he a demon is he just
an innocent person for whom people are
imparting onto them onto him their own
worst fears whatever is he leland gaunt
from from from needful things or is he a
splinter in the world and that splinter
is causing things to infect around the
entry site like that the kids should not
be here then Castle Rock is where the
manifestations of him not it's the is
the earth resisting him actually being
here right rejecting the ejecting the
the the new the new visitor from another
land and and that had taken a bunch of
different forms in the room but there
was he carries chaos in his wake and all
things will fall beyond him some of it
was directed some of it wasn't some of
it was accidental all of that kind of
again kind of fell by the wayside in
favor of this slightly more esoteric
version of he doesn't know if things are
happening things may or may not be
happening we almost never see them
happening but it's a lot of the legend
of the kid seems to follow him where he
goes sure and also lots of death and
stuff yes but like death you rarely get
to see or is he and here's another
question about how time works because if
time is splintering in this world if
time is splintering in this world which
it is then is he witnessing when he goes
in and he watches this family that's
sitting down to have some cake is he
inspiring a meltdown and a turn to
violence or is he witnessing a piece of
violence that happened in the past
because when he's hearing things he's
hearing things they're happening oh the
dead body which we know is stand by me
the body and he's hearing things from
different periods of time so answer my
question sir was that past or present
if it is present okay yeah the only time
traveler in the show is Ruth okay
and even her time travel is dementia
really but we are we are almost always
aside from the occasional like flashback
that we see in current time moving
forward so when he goes to the house and
he climbs up to the roof and you hear
that family kill themselves they're
actually killing him themselves with him
on the roof of their house okay yeah
yeah right
sick what Ruth the Queen Ruth [ __ ]
Spacek of all the Yummy's all the Emmys
yeah that is that is we are in her
perspective and subjectively for her
she's bouncing through time but that is
not objectively in the show it is just
in her in her brain she cannot keep time
in his writing that's correct order so
she could pass to pass the President to
pass to pass and right and sure this is
one of this is really one of my favorite
episodes of television that I've seen in
a number of years was the Queen her
episode because it is this amazing
metaphor for dementia but it also is
like but it is a Time fracture because
she's aware she's aware of when she has
the conversation with Molly she says
well you've never said that before which
means she's aware of these subtle
differences and these changes which
means that it can change which means
there was not dead answer the question
well it's not that it doesn't change
because she still she's again she's not
time-traveling and she's not affecting
any other time quote-unquote timeline
that she's in the things that are
different are different for her because
she's off her meds okay and so she is
observing the sort of dementia swirl in
a different way than she usually does
and she had been locked into one
particular version of the past that
she's a lot
in new information into that version of
the past so yeah she's not she's not
she's not gonna save any whales you know
to then like suddenly oh [ __ ] castle
rock is fine because they went back in
time and save the [ __ ] whales and I
went back and everything is okay it is
still just that would save everything
would it [ __ ] [ __ ] spacek piling a
starship for the whales I'm gonna pitch
that tomorrow how does that work do you
own the ideas that you pitch on the show
well probably not however there is an
idea that I pitched and I still love
that we didn't use that I will try and
put in something else okay all right
that means that I still own the bad
pitches that I'm gonna make on the show
that no one would buy oh ho yeah good
excellent so let's talk about a little
bit so it feels like there are rules and
I'm wondering when you're working on
this this is so layered like it hits the
hardcore Stephen King fans it hits the
casual kind of like I watched the movies
in red misery fan and like and then and
then it just works as a show you don't
have to have touched any of King which
is amazing so what kind of matrix are
you dealing with do you have the people
that are on the Easter eggs and those
that do character development and you're
like let's kill some people well I mean
the way the room the way almost any
writers room works is it works macro to
micro right like you're starting day one
in the writers room we all get together
well you know order lunch because it's
all about lunch in the writers room and
we'll start thinking blue sky like if
this show could be anything what could
it be
you know the show letters having ideas
like they've got a character they've got
a setting we had between 9:00 and 11:00
Stephen King works to choose from where
the rights to so we have the rights to
Rita Hayworth in the Shawshank
Redemption we have the rights to the
shining they had the rights to Dolores
Claiborne we have the rights to the
Green Mile and so it was all right well
let's read a bunch of books let's see
what we can absorb what we can and what
we can learn about how Steven King tells
stories right and then we go from the
here's what we feel like the whole show
is - all right let's cut that into ten
separate slices and what does it feel
like we're these characters doing
about the show and and in that point
you're not really considering so much of
the the tropes and the rules of genre it
is more let's just talk about people
let's talk about where we want them to
start where we want them to end what we
want them to learn what we want them how
we want them to change over that time
and then as we start even getting more
granular than that it becomes alright
well how does the world work like are we
going to haze as parallel universes is
it is it not are we sure are we not is
it is it not are you sure you're not it
is okay it's yes to parallel universes
the skismo is the sound of those
universes grinding together wait a
minute yes so does that mean the kids
unreliable narrative story is real is
that what actually happened come on I
believe I believe who thinks that that's
what happened that the kid came from
this other world and they why I got one
I got two at this 3/4 not majority do
not okay but we're right I mean I choose
to believe it only because as a
storyteller you have to believe that
there's a firm ground beneath you you
know and that lets you tell the rest of
those stories if that is this is going
to be our our our like start on [ __ ]
monopoly like this is go go is parallel
universes this kid got sucked through
here because Henry could hear it in a
way that nobody could we wanted to do
this great scene that that that never
happened but how the Devers adopted
Henry is they went to the Winchell
Hospital and Matthew Bieber crazy
[ __ ] Matthew Deaver sure had a tuning
fork and would like banging the fork and
like walk by each [ __ ] crib and the
kid who cried was the kid who they were
going to adopt because he knew he wanted
somebody who had some weird you know
aural ability to hear frequencies in
nobody else could hear and he had
figured out exactly what their frequency
this gizmo was and was finding the boy
who could hear it for him and then
raising him to be the awful [ __ ]
lightning rod for
universe travel right and so then the
kid Henry Deaver alternate universe ever
years because here's like needful things
are so present in this for me it just
felt the most like needful things for
most of the season but then I was
thinking about well what are the
temptations and they're they're really
right there like Alan is tempted by the
idea that the kid can cure the
Alzheimer's even though he's already met
the devil does he not remember it
happened not that long ago yeah there
was a little bit of like how much does
he remember the dark ages of Casiraghi
but how much it's so like how I'm gonna
come back to the idea of the kid but how
much does a character like Alan remember
the events of the other books and
stories that he's but that character has
been a part of I mean we would like to
say that he remembers all of it or in a
sort of pious PTSD haze has decided not
to remember some of it
you know like if even if the devil
visits your town more than once I can
see that being a thing you don't really
want to cop to or even convince yourself
that it was a delusion in some way you
know like am I gonna believe if I'm if
I'm sure Brody how many sharks do I
think you're going to [ __ ] land on a
MIDI main so many more than you would
think yes apparently but like I can see
a world and and they're like bitter mean
sharks they're not [ __ ] around these
are me girl sharks but they won't follow
you to the Bermuda especially a Lou
Gossett jr. round you know the version
of Alan Pangborn we were working with
was a version of Alan Pangborn who
experienced a bunch of [ __ ] put it
behind him once he retired he just put
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] in the closet and
left and only cared about him and Ruth
was his North Star and as long as he
could be with her for whatever time they
had left he was fine and even when the
bad [ __ ] comes back if it gets in the
way of him and Ruth he he will deal with
it if it doesn't affect him and Ruth he
doesn't give a [ __ ] so the very very
biggest temptation to me is that entire
for us as the audience and is that
entire narrative of
alternate universe that is so much more
happy where people feel better
everything's brighter it's just a little
more optimistic this is the universe
that the kid comes from so to me it's
like if that is real and that is an
option a why would we not just didn't
fade it and kill our alternate selves
and have better lives that's a side
question that's a side question but also
if that's real then those 27 years
turned him into a monster yes
right turn him into the guy that would
want to kill his stepfather you know
like being being in prison by Matthew
beaver in the other world
black Henry that's the only way you can
tell the two apart
black Henry would have been and and
being confronted with the fact that his
father is adopted father hated and
psychologically abused his adopted
mother like there's a lot of reasons for
black Henry to want to kill Mathew
Deaver the the the being imprisoned by
him in another universe is actually like
the least of them to a certain degree
like you can you could buy a kid who
never went to another universe whose
father treated his mother and himself
that poorly who snapped the other
universe is just accelerant on that fire
that was already gonna go off how much
are you guys trolling us scale of one to
ten are you three just like it's minimal
trolling you know it was it was never
about like let's piss the fans off or
let's let's let's Chum the waters and
see what happens
it was more like you know a as we're
figuring out the story as we go what's
the most effective version of this thing
what's the most evocative version of
this thing and and this sort of ongoing
tussle between what is objectively real
and what is subjectively real like what
do our characters believe and then what
do we a storyteller show and and that
that lever kept getting adjusted as the
season went of like this is this is
totally what's happening like the the
Mali superpower was something that had
also
like there was a sort of scale through
which it vacillated from she's a [ __ ]
mutant with superpowers to just kind of
a social you know and and I think by the
end of this show we're more towards like
superpower were more toward so she can
feel things that people are feeling she
can in some way it's not quite the
shining but it's close but it's so close
but it's so close right it seems like
the shine right and then she even has
the same kind of reaction where she's
just like I got a drug myself and try
and keep it down I mean yeah there's
there's a real medical condition called
mirror-touch synesthesia where people
can like many words I know it's a ton of
words and like if I'm sitting opposite a
person I have this condition and that
person is eating I feel full like my
body absorbs and registers and other
person's physical sensations and
emotions can I catch that and then make
that work you talk to people who have
this condition and like you know sure
there's the awesome part of it which I'm
assuming sex is amazing but there's the
I that person is crying and I feel sad
and I don't know why that person feels
nauseous and I don't know why I feel
nauseous like I have no real agency over
my own body because I consistently
respond to everybody else around me and
the only way for them to navigate to the
world is to dull some of those senses
and tons of drug use sometimes
self-prescribed sometimes overprescribed
but that was the molle we were starting
to play with and then what happens of
that in medicine what happens at that
science nudges a little bit because
Castlerock has a [ __ ] up place right
and then the volume starts to kind of go
and then also Henry is kind of a trigger
for her totally Henry was always the one
she'd bonded with the most for reasons
that you know we never quite got into
but she had been obsessed with him as a
little girl like here's his little boy
is going out to the middle of the woods
in the middle of the night doing awful
[ __ ] here's this kid who's kind of
lonely because nobody seems to want to
talk to the weird black kid who just
disappeared for 12 days and his dad died
like there was this whole bond between
them yeah
the town reacts very poorly today
I found yeah it's not the most
accommodating yeah pretty nasty hey
killer yeah then he did try to kill him
so they had a point so let's talk about
though Molly and this is what I mean she
you there's some amazing and I don't
know if you guys have been online and
looked at some of these fan theories
they're great and and you can find
anything on reddit don't but there's
like okay look how much of this is
pointed at how much of it is just
playing a little bit right so she walks
in and she's in a red cloak and
something has taken her over when she
does the murder and then later she's in
the yellow raincoat so all of this to me
is tying her visually to skarsgård and
the kid who is maybe someone else or
working as a minion for someone else
like a crimson king or something like
this and that it wasn't Henry our Henry
that was inspiring her to do that murder
but it was alternate universe henry's
arrival
Jr's dormant saying like how much of
that is like you're implanting it so
that people pick up these threads and go
down a rabbit hole and how much of it is
just there to mess around and be like oh
it is also a thing it was never it was
never designed to be a messing with the
audience's heads it was always designed
to keep you guessing as to a witch Henry
she felt a kinship too and as we saw in
episode 9 when you go to the other the
world I had a very close bond and then
Molly over there was not [ __ ] up like
she probably had a little touch of that
she was very empathetic but was not
pushed to the extremes that our molly is
and her bond with henry via the sort of
red sweatshirt the red hoodie is real as
is when he comes like she felt in the
room we tried to get this idea that she
could feel everybody's feeling when she
was around them what troubled her the
most about him was that she felt nothing
that he was this black hole of emotion
of agency of anything like she just
couldn't get a read and that's like I've
got great hearing and suddenly I walk
into
when there's no sound at all and that's
deeply unsettling to her and and she was
you know we were drawn to that because
she understood that like it's a thing
I've never I've never felt quiet in my
entire life
this guy's quiet it freaks me out but it
also kind of jazz's me and so let me get
closer to this flame that I totally
shouldn't get closer to so as you
unravel these threads in the season to
come but first of all do you guys want
them to go back to Castle Rock or do you
want to go that overlooked show of hands
like who wants to go to the Overlook but
we can't go I'm pitching it right now
[Laughter]
let's go to Salem's Lot to to the best
of my knowledge this is a this is a show
that's built to be a anthology of
season-long anthology and so whatever
the next story will be will not be
continuation if this that's not to say
that I now write blue balls that [ __ ]
yeah that is not to say that much like
Fargo like characters do sort of wind
their ways between seasons and events
that took place in the past might have
effects in the future but we will not be
picking up season 2 episode 1 with like
I will following Jane levy as she goes
the Overlook Hotel like that's probably
not going to happen
well there's still so much more here
though that didn't get addressed let's
talk about the 27 years and how there's
no way that's a coincidence answer the
question I will I will also say that
that per my previous answer like ello
legalese the 27 years will probably not
be investigated at season 2 either but
the 27 years that young Henry was in the
other world that white Henry was in our
world is real okay yes Constance
that's a real answer that's so much more
of an answer
for season two a castle rock well he did
a podcast see and told everything it
doesn't rely on that though this show
does not rely on that it really doesn't
it's it's not like a one-trick pony show
at all because I mean I think that's
really true like there's just so much to
dive into it thing there's there's still
a lot of story left in Castle Rock and
there's a lot of story left and Stephen
King that we do have control over that
we can we can twist and massage and
manipulate into a season - they will
still feel resonant with this woman so
have the echoes of this one but be new
story new characters new everything did
you track the theories not at all
primarily because we wrote the show last
year you know and and I had not been
engaged with the show in a real way
until after it came out you know like I
was in the room from February to October
of last year I was unset for my episode
and I got to see a cut of my episode in
like February of last year or so of this
year I'm sorry and and once it came out
it was I want to watch the show because
I want to see what the [ __ ] we did
mm-hmm
because it was a bananas [ __ ] show
with bonkers [ __ ] scripts and like
how do you do this I'm gonna watch and
find out but I didn't really engage with
the deep dive in the theory so I was
never that guy really like even lost I
was never like oh I have friends who
were I have colleagues who were nothing
but respect for those who did but I was
just never that guy that was also the
most apt description of bad robot that
I've ever and we're all gonna show up
there now he doesn't count
yeah I wish that was also my
aspirational quitting of my job so screw
you screen junkies I'm done pretty much
I wish he wasn't all he doesn't get all
that involved right like it's not in a
really direct way JJ JJ operates because
he bad robot produces so [ __ ] much
which we movie is in between stuffy
directs between you know the 12 shows
having a year at any given time he can't
actually be overly involved in anything
the thing he can do for you is make the
phone calls that get answers immediately
so it's hey we kind of we're thinking
about going after [ __ ] spacek we're not
sure she's just interested you want me
to give her a call yeah JJ that'd be
great
and JJ call says it's basic and she says
I'll be in your show you know like he's
he's the [ __ ] like if Barack Obama
was a white dude with glasses and could
get anybody on the phone that's what
that is like you know so he's you
800-pound gorilla but you send in and
just like Bauer buy all through doors
and get [ __ ] done he was very interested
in the first script and the pilot both
on script level and in the in the
cutting of the pilot when we had shot it
and very interested in like the
marketing of it but he was never like a
hands-on person like bad robot would
give us notes but it was never JJ it was
somebody else a bad robot Hulu would
give us notes but then they were all
great but it was very much like you know
JJ would like this to happen whatever
you want which note was terrible they
weren't all great come on
you were all great there was there's no
there's no world in which every note is
great you know the the note you
frequently got the most was connective
tissue like how do we know all of these
strands you're gonna tie together but
part of the part of the weird tension
between the bad robot waves telling
stories and the Stephen King way of
telling stories is that bad robot is all
about the mystery bad roll I mean you've
seen JJ's TED talk it's the mystery box
it's the let me let me let me tease you
with the bomb under the chair before I
ever show it going off and I'm not as
interested in what happens at the end of
it as much than the questions that we do
for it Stephen King does not give a [ __ ]
about mystery Stephen King is like what
is it
Kujo how do you know it's in the [ __ ]
title what is it Christine how do you
know it's in the [ __ ]
like he never hides the ball
it's what's doing it it's it huh what's
it forget demon clown page 5 of that
book demon clown he's never it's never a
mystery it's more like I'm going to
establish these human characters and
drop the [ __ ] supernatural on them
and see how they react to it
so how those two storytelling modes kind
of got together was that weird alchemy
of all right we have to kind of build a
mystery to make bad robot happy but we
also need to not hide so much of the
mystery to make Stephen King fans happy
and in hulu was like just tell us how
this [ __ ] connects just tell us how
it makes sense you know the more clarity
we can have the better and that was
always the tension was like clarity
versus obfuscation the versus being bald
about it being hiding it and and I think
we kind of got to a happy medium of all
of that stuff I think it feels very
talking because look I'm surprised he
wasn't more involved because the chess
pieces alone are straight out of JJ I
mean that's like good and evil play God
and the devil are playing again when
you're the chess piece you know is all
in lost towards the end of it yeah I
mean the the the Queen episode was an
entirely Sam Shaw invention because his
mother had passed away the week before
we were set to open the room and she
suffered from dementia and so he spent
the front half of the season just
processing it just dealing with the loss
of his mom and like settling her estate
and going through her house and all of
that stuff that the excavation of a life
and the reckoning with that particular
kind of demise weighed heavily on him
and so the chess pieces thing was not
surprising at all that it's I think a
thing that his mom had done like that I
need these anchors in the world so I can
come back to the people that I love and
be present for them while they're here
and bad robot and I think had almost
nothing to say about that script we in
the room were like hey it wouldn't be
cool if she was a time travel is a great
and then he just delivered a script like
we never broke that episode in the room
it was Sam's gonna go off and write and
he came back and deliver the script
because it was all it was all part of I
think
the healing processes coping process and
and I think you can see it you
absolutely can that's a beautiful
episode of not yet that makes it more so
as well as the idea that that by
stealing this kid Alan removed at least
in one world the single human that could
have healed her in the way that he
desired and destroyed it that's like
there's there's just a lot in there I
think in terms of this idea of the sins
of the past bubbling up but also you
know you're looking at the character
that secure hero Henry one and he's he's
attempted murder um through Molly he's
done a murder
yeah and and how two people could be
bonded by that kind of act and feel real
love and real attraction and real lust
for each other the source of which is
like the the tree from that fruit is
rotten is that we killed the person
together that's what we're bonded that's
why we're so close and then we did an
awful thing like Mickey and Mallory but
like way less fun yeah she also wants to
do it with him now I'm pretty sure
[Music]
oh they did they totally did it
yeah they did it but should I I feel
like I should let you guys ask questions
too right like should I you sure what
they're gonna open it's an actual human
JC JC is running around with a mic for
people who have a can I can I tell you
you can stay here tonight see my
favorite thing that I pitched in the
room that we didn't use yeah very early
on but halfway through the to the run of
the show we we kept on revolving around
us as a parallel universe is what's
wrong with caps Rock does have an
original sin what's going on and I was
like okay let's imagine for a second
that there was a teenage girl couple
thirty years ago had a really awful
experience in high school she may or may
not be a telekinetic she may or may not
had it like a pig's blood incident she
may or may not have like set a town on
fire and and so but what if like in
order to cover up the weirdness of it
all like she just get dropped in the
witness protection program she just gets
you know she gets assigned in her name
she gets given a new hometown and let's
pretend that that hometown is now Castle
Rock and let's pretend that woman is now
Ruth Deaver and so what happens if the
most powerful telepath in the world is
losing her mind so dangerous so like is
that was that the initial tear between
the universe's is that why that she was
happening is that why the morality is
off the scale is that way it feels like
calsilica is tearing itself apart
because this woman's mind is tearing
yourself apart and the response was like
yeah we don't have the rights to carry
I'm like you don't need them you got the
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] spacek yeah you
got can't standing right there like 80%
of that work is [ __ ] spacek and she's
right there yeah all we need to do is
just say remember that time she blew up
with her mind yeah that was [ __ ] up
and if everybody gets
yeah and then eventually it was like
it's just it's too close we can't do it
I'm like that's right I'm a hip pocket
yeah she just needs to throw a couple of
knives always good and hear a little bit
of soft laughing and be really pissed up
about it also is there a way that the
world splits and then Professor X enters
and they work together and old man fence
racks
Logan crossover season three hey hey are
you doing good to see you again good to
be seen so I have a question it's a
thread that I don't know if it kind of
just was a red herring or not but there
was an episode I haven't watched it
since it came out late where he stumbles
upon a house cuz I guess he's trying to
black Henry mm-hmm he's trying there you
go it's the only way to do it or it's
kind of cool so he stumbles upon a house
cuz he's trying to retrace his steps
kind of trying to see what happened in
the past and he stumbles upon this uh
this kind of like run-down house and
there's like a barber the white barber
that's in there and it seems to be where
he was and he's like well you remember
me
remember I didn't touch you and I'm like
I felt like that was gonna go somewhere
and it kind of like never went back
there or did I just miss an episode
where no no there's no more episode
there cuz I felt like that kind of gave
me hints aware well something really
happened here versus all that other
stuff is just supernatural and they're
trying to make it up but nothing ever
corroborated that so I couldn't really
know the the idea was initially anyway
that when Henry came back before he gets
found by what's-his-face Allen Pangborn
he dropped it on the dudes house and
weird awful pseudo [ __ ] kind of happened
but I don't think that at the end of the
day it landed that well in the show yeah
I interpret it as that's where he was
and that's why he was trying to go to
the backyard he was like was I here was
this the cage that I was in versus the
other place the the impulse the impulse
there was to give both Henry and the
audience two equally valid theories as
to what happened in the woods
12 days were you held in a [ __ ] cage
by this dude or were you in a parallel
universe for 27 years one of them sounds
more plausible one of them is true and
and trying to quite troll the audience
but leave that irresolution hanging in
the air so that you could kind of push
the mystery further and then live in
that sense of I'm not entirely sure
because the character is not entirely
sure does that make sense
congratulations oh thank you
we have have some tickets to give away
to the Ripley's Believe It or Not [ __ ]
up Museum just down the street
Thank You Man oh hi Jamie how are you
I'm good thank you
I am very excited that you have a female
guest that really made me happy as Roth
is amazing but my question is about if
you know maybe you don't the music
choices do they have to do with the
characters like when Molly goes and
makes her drug deal they're playing
hybrid moments by the misfits or when
and I I didn't understand it is it you
said black Henry and is the other one
white Henry truth okay we got to look
when he's messing with Ruth he puts on
Roy Orbison are those choices run by you
who decides because they work well all
the choices then babe those choices are
first put in at the script level at the
like the writers like I would love for
my money the best version of this is
like gene pick nice 24 hours to Tulsa
and that would be amazing if we could
get it
but if we can't get it something that
feels like it and then it goes up the
chain and then you shoot the episode and
you put the song in there because why
the [ __ ] not and then it becomes music
clearances like how much will it cost us
for these songs how much will it cost us
to get the rights and air it and if it's
not that bad we can afford it or if we
feel like we desperately need to have it
then then that's where that conversation
happens but it starts from the writers
and from the showrunners and and from
there it blossoms so the rest of the
production did you have any choices in
your episode which was six I believe the
one thing that I wanted to get in there
that never got in there was the idea
that that Henry Deaver black Henry
Deaver as a black kid growing up in a
white town in what would have been the
late 80s Early 90s would have been way
into like fishbone and Public Enemy and
and like trying to claim your blackness
in a place that doesn't often give you
purchase for that to a certain degree
like over-the-top like [ __ ] listening
to like Farrakhan speeches and all of
that stuff so that you could you get to
have a sense of culture that it seems to
be separate from you that never made it
in there cuz we never had the alike you
know hears in his room with Wendell and
Wendell presses the [ __ ] tape because
there's a damn daddy was a lotta LL Cool
J I know as a jingling baby go ahead
baby and like but none of that you to
that scene just never happened so we
never got to hear like the music that
Henry loves as much as we did the music
that other people loved that does make
sense
thank you sho'nuff usually like tickets
ii crazy ass museum hi how's it going
it's great man how are you I'm doing
pretty good are you buying a venom shirt
yes
I know I'm probably disappointed right
now all these reviews actually so I
guess technically like you could also
weigh in on like your opinion on it so
like all the death that like goes on in
the town during Castle Rock like
everyone says it's like because of the
kid or white Henry Deaver and like my
interpretation of like what's going on
is that think of it like an equation
basically because white Henry Devers
from like this other universe in this
universe that is not is just trying to
balance itself out so it's just killing
people wildly to try and get back to
that centralized you know like
equilibrium so like that's my
interpretation of it I don't really
think that he's evil or whatnot I just
think it's like part of this equation
that needs to be balanced out I just
want to see if maybe like what your
thoughts were on that as well and if you
could weigh in on a theories yes no it
is it is all about balance and if in
episode 10 if Henry had took it upon
himself to and I don't know what the
mechanics of putting a dude back in his
universe look like but if he could
somehow have taken white Andy Deaver and
shoved him through the bug in the
universe anus and come out the other
side everything would be fine like both
of those universes would be okay like
the people are where they're supposed to
be everything is how it's supposed to be
we can all go off and like not have to
keep children in [ __ ] cages that
would be great but because Henry doesn't
do that black Henry you're still left
with this imbalance somebody's got to be
in a [ __ ] cage in order for the world
to keep turning and and that's the the
weight that black Henry is willing to
carry there's the burden he's willing to
bear is I've got to be the warden I've
got to be the last good man in Castle
Rock question
follow-up question so I feel like there
were a couple of theories one was that
he was kind of like the opposite of John
Coffey and like if he touched you you
would
not be healed you would die or bad do
bad things he would bring out the worst
in you not the best the other one is
that the kid is Randall Flagg yeah okay
I will say we did not have the race of
the stand but there were conversations
which she just [ __ ] make him Randall
Flagg and ultimately it was no okay so
then but then he's not so then it's like
a body part
it's like rejecting if you get it
somebody's liver and in your body's
rejecting it that's how the earth is
behaving right it's trying to it's
creating all kinds of chaos in the
entire system to reject this thing and
push it out but there was crazy stuff
happening in Castle Rock before that yep
right well I think I think it is the 27
years is when the crazy she was happy
he's endearing exactly but he's a Darius
mother far away plus in the opening
credits dairy circles with a red pen
like it's significant plus it is bill
skarsgård it is bill scars burg with
those big big eyes that is another thing
was like we got that skarsgård people
can I think he's penny wise like should
we disabuse them of that notion by the
way I never gave a negative review for
venom tonight let's carry up
does that come close to approximately an
answer or I I would think so okay all
right well then you get where are we
going next juicy hey guys James James
how are you doctor alright question do
the birds or the sparrows simile is the
same thing in council rock that they do
in the dark half remind me what they
symbolized in the dark half passes to
other worlds to a different world in in
an hour show the idea was that birds are
very sensitive to subsonic frequencies
and the skismo
is one of those frequencies and so
there's something about castle rock the
location of it that causes all [ __ ] to
go wrong that's ultimately why I think
bad things that have happened in Castle
Rock happen is because that schism is
also driving people [ __ ] crazy
and so the birds spiraling and then
crashing to the ground and weird awful
avian flu [ __ ] is all I think the result
of the skismo at least that's how I
choose to interpret the [ __ ] we made
up about birds and subsonic frequencies
[Applause]
but yeah it is not it's that - it's not
supposed to be supernatural it's
supposed to be a natural side effect of
weird [ __ ] in the town and yeah [ __ ] how
much alcohol did you need after seeing
venom did you guys like zombie like that
much so far tonight
did you like zombie land do we like the
same director is Zombieland so if you
could imagine sort of kind of doing a
zombie land like comedy but it's venom
and it's a buddy comedy with Eddie Brock
and venom but except for the first 15
minutes aren't that that's the movie but
you know what it did give us it brought
us back to the day of the the like do
you remember when Will Smith used to
sing the plot of a movie at the end of
the movie we have now I'm excited this
tom hardy sing the plot of the movie at
the end of it that would be [ __ ]
amazing is even the bane voice venom
should we be doing it so he he doesn't
he doesn't do the bane voice entirely
Eddie does it's a really thick accent
but but Venom's like really sassy yeah I
kind of a dick this is so crazy it's
venom a [ __ ] a little bit the [ __ ] is
somebody on the galaxy touch of [ __ ]
symbiote Wow listen I was on the fence
about venom before like why do we need a
venom movie minimum was like the least
interesting part of spider-man 3 which
had no more interesting parts in it but
then and now I gotta see this [ __ ]
venom
I mean I I think you should see it with
your own eyes
it's like how much of a six-pack well I
mean all of the six-pack all right I'll
just put it on my shirt people are gonna
love it or hate it
is my guess not literally but is that
not everything look you know what you're
gonna like this or you won't
it's it's got the kernel of being the
weirdest most amazing twist on a
comic-book movie but they just didn't go
all the way there that's my review all
right I don't know why I just put that
on the youtubes I am NOT looking at the
comments also this is a really weird way
to get filmed because the cameras are
hidden so you think they're not here but
they are oh yeah I'm sorry did you have
more things I did you know in the
shining or maybe you don't know how
Danny Torrance he's kind of a he's
talking to if you haven't seen the
spoilers he's talking to himself that
ratty old herself black Henry sees
himself is he able to communicate with
himself the way Danny is with that kind
of shiny
no no Henry Henry Deaver has no
supernatural abilities really other than
like a crazy sensitivity to that sound
so if anybody could be able to do that
it would be it would be Jane Leeves
character given that she is a Torrence
right she is the niece of Jack Torrance
but she's kind of bitter for not having
had those kinds of experiences a little
bit yeah but now she's killing
[ __ ] so yeah this is the
weirdest law and order situation in this
town where they're like yeah you're fine
get out of here the initial idea had
been that
that Castlerock was an unincorporated
town like so much bad should happen so
many people left that the town had voted
to dis incorporate which meant you have
no services in the town you had to count
on the state police to come we have to
count on like federal [ __ ] like
disaster relief to put out a fire and so
it's a bit lawless like you could come
to Castle Rock and commit a murder and
nobody would be there to catch you
because there's no cops anywhere also
they fail to suspect the people that are
right in front of them so frequently
isn't a cop anymore
let's talk to the psychic it's your
partner like tickets to museum time
[Music]
alright this this is the last question
to get tickets but I will keep answering
questions until you [ __ ] get
sleepy so the GAO I mean I do but so
first of all mark mark I loved you APIs
ode thought it was really creepy over
here and you lock dude in a box and you
know I was kind of weirded out he he
trusted the other black guy who ya skin
ain't kinfolk man my question is more
you being in this story room what's up
with this guy breaking into all of these
houses you know it's like you're the
only black guy in the whole town and you
keep like just walking into people's
homes did you tell them that might not
be a cool thing for him to do or like
did they did they consult you on this
kid spot me on there breaking and
entering
no like honestly it hadn't occurred to
me how much breaking entering Henry does
until you mentioned it right
if I if I had twig tonight I'm like hey
guys baby let's not have the black dude
keep breaking into [ __ ] people's
houses you would think he would know
better he's also a lawyer seems like I
got the law on my side but he does he
doesn't know he doesn't at all
then again he's breaking into my lady's
house so maybe she just wouldn't know he
breaks into the breakfast and I'm just
like point he's mostly crazy well it's
the same house but it's new owners yeah
maybe so he'll be broken into the one
house he just broke into a choice with
two different owners at Merck did he
break into more houses all right yes we
are we should attract that closer we
should have put somebody on B&E duty
count them off oh [ __ ] maybe Henry
should maybe not break into this dad's
house
knock on a door Tommyknockers you talk
about right since you guys had access to
no I don't think we ever thought about
Tom manadonese we were just looking for
a way to tie Henry being in that prison
and Henry's inciting incident for
beginning to doubt his own mind and
beginning to open himself up to the idea
of the supernatural and so the the the
the gunshot in the ear and the tinnitus
and the skismo
and all of those things began to be the
same kind of thread the same kind of
thrown like we could we could we could
freight that with as much story as we
wanted to and that eventually hopefully
pay it off in a way that made it make
sense from the beginning
hilarious I know I tell the best boring
anecdotes oh you want tickets come get
your tickets hoorah
alright how are you hey number one is
when a Mira what Marie said thank you so
much filter is fantastic
the the tension of ramps up I mean when
when Henry comes in meets an Odin and
and Willy in the woods the tension just
keeps building building building to the
end of that episode which takes you
right into the Queen and I don't think
you earn the Queen without that that
tension rising so thank you well thank
you
number one who killed Odin what was it
uh was it Willy what is Willy it's Willy
okay Willy
because Willy was going to be purified
he was going to be cleansed and ready
for the coming schism Athan or whatever
and he ultimately said [ __ ] that that
sounds like an awful idea to like burn
my eardrums out so no deaf dude in the
forest I'm not going to do that thank
you
yeah the most like I was on set for that
part of it I thought tonight we shot in
Massachusetts doubling for Maine and and
we shot that at since its night and you
need as much night as you can we got to
the location like 7 o'clock at night and
we shot until 4:00 a.m. in the morning
and the actor CJ Jones who played Odin
had the flu and is for real death like
he's hard of hearing like so everything
that he's learning he's learning through
an interpreters during to reading the
the directorial advice would have to go
through an interpreter and so it was the
longest most wonderful process because
he's also a great actor and super open
to things but the weirdest thing was
that Kieran Culkin is playing Willy was
memorizing he just he had the [ __ ]
monologue like he's doing all the
[ __ ] speaking but we had to make sure
that he was in time with the signage
otherwise because we were very conscious
that there are going to be deaf people
watching this show
and if he is faster than CJ signing
they're gonna that gets gonna ruin
everything so we just kept that stop
dude you so you speaking too fast he
can't sign fast enough and then
translating all of this through an
interpreter and I've never felt this
guilty about writing exterior woods
night and like I'm there and it's
[ __ ] 40 degrees in the woods and like
guys I'm so sorry this could have been
extremely woods day this could have been
interior McDonald's and we all cabin
either [ __ ] McNuggets and talking
about the skismo
but we're here in the [ __ ] woods and
it's my bad it's all good man we get
paid a lot and night shoots are like
time and a half so thanks buddy buying
Christmas presents for my children as a
location person that worked in Boston I
hear yes there's no joke and we also
stumbled into like a hive of bees
who were angry because it was just was
October so like he was about to go from
fall to winter and they were furious and
we're just trumpeting the [ __ ] woods
and suddenly you see like eight crew
dudes ripping their shirts off running
through the woods screaming because they
stepped on beehives and they got [ __ ]
bit real bad and one do to have to go to
the hospital because this [ __ ]
said exterior woods so I'm sorry Chad
for what happened to you in the woods
that day workman's comp second question
if you got the call to be showrunner of
season two what would you like to see
happen if I got the call to be short of
a season two which will not happen
because they have a show on for season
two and they've already started working
and I'm not in it no it's not their
fault at all honestly it's all my fault
tread stone that's the multiple multiple
country's yeah that's the problem is
that the the scheduling did not work out
in my favor and they were starting to
castle roxies into room yesterday and I
am on Treadstone from the two months and
so those those particular gears couldn't
match so sadly will not be there for
season two but if I was doing season 2 I
think vampires yeah I think Salem's Lot
I think you lean heavy on Salem's Lot
they do tease it and then there's also
this idea of kind of warring mythology's
to a certain degree because another
thing we discovered in the research for
season four season one was that Maine is
home to a you know number of Somali
immigrants like refugees just get like
landed in Maine and so there are these
towns that have never again not the
lily-white astounds ever anymore because
some of this is entire community of
people from someplace wildly exotic and
totally different and so how do the
comparative mythology's of northeastern
Maine but up against the competitor
mythology's of Africa and I think that
kind of cultural clash could be
fascinating thank you I have no tickets
we go hey Mark what's up hey man how you
doing good good it's first time here so
it's pretty good yeah are you are you Ed
Sheeran trying to cover your accent oh
my god but I get that a lot I mean
that's that's cool I wish I wish ladies
would thank that but that's not but
anyway back to Castle Rock so two
questions first thing is all of what we
discussed about the kid right in the
last episode there are two visual cues
that kind of threw me off
one is where they're in the woods and
you see that demon face to go on the
demon face yeah and the set and the
second was when he smiles at the end
where we have that pan on long lens and
he smiles was that just meant to be a
trolling device or is that meant to
second-guess us or what's behind it man
well the demon face is ultimately there
I believe that it's what Henry sees that
lets him justify putting that kid in the
cage Henry now believes that this guy's
monstrous he now believes that he's an
agent of evil Henry is at the end of his
rope he's at the the frayed tether of
his reality and his grip on what's
happening in the real world versus
whatever other fucked-up world and he
sees this vision of horror and that is
what lets him sleep at night knowing
that that kids in a cage and I think the
smile is a little bit of a troll not so
much of a troll is just a a throw
forward to a story that you sadly will
never get to see until like season four
where we go back to Castle Rock and we
go back to Shawshank
and then skarsgård is done being a movie
star and wants to do TV again so it was
a demon face not an old man face looked
a little bit to me like an old man yeah
like an ageless stranger or son looked
like a wraith I saw it as Jesus yeah
that's that that's that's my
interpretation of it okay that I believe
was the intention behind it and yeah the
last little smile is evil are still down
here and evil evil has the best time
even in a cage cool and my second
question is since follow-up to Jason's
since can't be back for season two if
you were at the showrunner for season
three
what would you want to do that season 3
of Castle Rock maximum [ __ ] overdrive
that'd be awesome
there's no agent truck right thanks
mother truckers so alright since we now
live in a world where more toys are
going into the same toy chests and like
more properties are able to play with
more things and more licenses they're
all becoming one creating this show do
you leave certain things open because
maybe in the future hey there are talks
that we might be we don't have this
license because you hinted it about it
earlier tonight you know certain things
were shut down because you don't have
the rights to it but do you guys know as
you're creating the show that there are
talks or there might be negotiations or
companies might be coming together where
in the future yes you will have those
rights and you will be able to tell
those stories so from a rider standpoint
do you leave things a little more
open-ended because you know certain
things or that's just kind of how the
cookies crumble it's a little bit of how
the cookies crumble to the best of my
knowledge where Warner Brothers TV was
the entity that had there was the rights
holder for most of that stuff and Warner
Brothers I don't think is going anywhere
that said they could buy another company
that has other [ __ ] that's lying around
yeah but I think going into it it's it's
it's less a matter of like leaving [ __ ]
for the future and more what can be the
best version of this story for today and
and these are the pieces we have to play
with right now let's tell the best
[ __ ] story we can with these pieces
and if we get to do more later then
great we'll find new pieces or if
somebody comes to us and says oh yeah by
the way if you wanted the rights to
Creepshow you could have Creepshow also
it's like that'd be amazing thank you
that's that's now like [ __ ] yes
please we'll do all of it but we can't
ever really bank on
having more than we have when we start
and leaving too much in the tank for the
next season because you want to leave it
all in the field if you can so off the
success of season 1 and you guys are
going for season 2 do you guys get a
little bit more juice or pool to say
like hey we should go fight for this
without getting in trouble I mean I can
I can say with know free of reprisal
because they can't not not hire me
because I'm already not hired I don't
think they're I think they have juice
because it did well you know I think
that that Hulu was behind it bad robots
behind it war but there's TVs behind it
they want the best version of a season
to you they can have but I don't think
that there's been a request made to go
out and get something that they don't
already have or that they wanted but
that said you know that's again be
800-pound gorilla of JJ is hey man you
know it'd really be great can you get us
the rights to this it's like [ __ ] get
us the rights to Walking Dead see what
you can do and he can try and see what
happens but I don't I don't know if
there's a if there's a Golden Snitch out
there that they really want to get their
hands on all right I just want to see if
we've had a little Potter though Ozone's
Harry Potter well you know you if you
get enough toys to play together I was
always a boy who had a bunch of toys and
my friend had a bunch of toys and we
played together and you have Power
Rangers and I have Ninja Turtles and now
let's bring those together and have fun
so yeah yeah I would if we're gonna do
that I would pitch them on like Castle
Rock season 3 : Arkham Asylum because
why the [ __ ] not
right walk me through that real quick
Warner Brothers also owns DC well you
know what's happening in Arkham who's
there who is it the kid like been
transferred somehow from shanked or
Arkham well I think and then there's
like a infiltrated rescue mission okay
which Harley
I think I think I think Jackie Torrance
and Harley Quinn yes right
[ __ ] thrill kill Kult right there
but it'd be fun to dream always fun to
dream thank you so much for tonight
thank you Michael preciate it
first I'm gonna do my impression of the
kid just real quick just yeah I don't I
still never quite understood why he's
kind of we have to go to the woods
sheriff you were happier listening I
figured it was because he's been leaning
up against like a cell gate all his life
I guess that was kind of his choice
maybe but yeah I did notice like just
the entire time he's just like this
first thing I want to say Nate is those
pants are amazing thank you target
target good job man thank you cancer you
for it well first I wanted to comment on
the fact that like you were questioning
whether or not you got that like you
succeeded in conveying the feel of
Stephen King and I think for me from
what I've been reading I've been like in
my first year of Stephen King binging
reading all the hits and stuff the thing
about Stephen King is it's not the
horror of what you understand it's the
horror of what you don't understand and
putting you in an experience that you're
not necessarily used to and that you
don't have all the answers for and it's
the horror of the experience of that and
I think that in terms of Castle Rock
like I don't think a lot of people
really got the cyclical kind of aspect
of where Henry ends up in the place at
the warden where he sees something in
the kid that he's not quite sure is real
but he has enough doubt in his mind to
keep him in a prison for 27 years and
then Henry has that same moment at the
end where he has to make that same call
do I kill this kid or do in my mind how
much doubt is reasonable to keep him
alive so I think in the sense of like
yeah the end has so many more questions
than our answer and I think a lot of
people get frustrated when the biggest
questions aren't answered and not the
little questions along the way that mean
more towards I think the big picture and
that's what I think succeeded in
the show so that was my interpretation
of that my question though is what was
your favorite Easter egg that got
pitched in the writing or whether or not
it got you know in the final cut or not
but like what was the favorite thing
like reference that was made that was
like okay that has to be in there I mean
my my dead Carrie pitch yeah was was my
favorite you know I think that another
thing we wanted to do was rather than
have Jackie Torrance be Jack Torrance's
niece she gotta be female Jack Torrance
she was going to be female Jack trying
not so and this part of the story was
going to be female Jack Torrance falling
in love with Henry's son when go
reincarnated Wendy says Jack and Wendy
and what happens when Jack and Wendy get
together in this particular thing they
make kid yeah like just awful [ __ ]
happens
but we we we once we backed away from
the reincarnation version and just
leaned into the into the Denice uncle
relationship and then Wendell we never
really got the romance between the two
of them so that never really never took
but I kind of loved that idea of
planting the seeds for what would be
eventually the shining kind of gender
swapped going forward that was
definitely when a guest was going like
that's where I was going but yeah it
obviously went when she still has that
you know shinin connection even though
it's the movie version and not the book
version because she says it's an axe and
not the rock mallet like in the book I'm
just being picky sorry yeah sorry and I
also I want to ask Roth what is your
favorite Easter Egg of the season that
you noticed because I have to watch it
and see all the ones that I missed for
sure but
let me think about I don't know because
I I think it's not the kind of thing
that they need that needs them you know
what I mean it was like I think the
story is so strong unto itself they're
fun though
and they're fun to help kind of give you
theories or that's the fun thing about
being online the shows like this is that
you can riff on different theories so I
think it's more like who and what is the
kid wasn't so much an easter egg but
that was my favorite through Lion the
biggest kind of hanging thread that you
wanted answered yeah because it every
because at every moment it was bringing
you to the question of what you
perceived to be evil may not be evil but
it also may be creating evil like even
little baby Reverend Deaver is he evil
was he born evil or is the woman that's
trying to strangle a baby evil
I thought maybe their baby got Pet
Sematary Yeah right gates very much gage
Pet Sematary but that question to me was
the most interesting question the whole
time and and then ultimately you're like
I guess everybody's evil and that's why
he's laughing
you just get [ __ ] yeah that scene in
the jail was pretty much stuff like yeah
and we also there was there was an idea
that the building that Molly's
refurbishing the it was supposed to be
an old mill and we wanted it to be a
paper mill so that the the the machine
from the Thresher or whatever their
Wrangler was sort of in the basement of
that machine kind of like you would just
look kind of take a little tour when the
kid was living there like you'd take a
little basement tour and see Oh giant
murder machine and then that kind of
would be it
thank you I think we're good we're gonna
do two more all right
my name is Danny this is my first time
this is a castle rock related but I just
kind of wanted to pick your brain as you
know a fellow fan of sorry I was always
wondering like if you were gonna be in
charge of say a Netflix show centered
around the character blade how would you
play that story out for the season and
what would be your list of issues for
your deep cuts well here's here's what
I'll say nobody's gonna hire me to make
a blade show I wish they would that be
great because I think that that right
now you can have a really interesting
conversation using blade to talk about
things like like urban violence things
like race because a big part of the
whole daywalker idea here's a guy caught
between two worlds who's a guy who is
almost by definition biracial in a way
and so being able to talk about not
belonging to either world but being part
of both and being a little bit
ostracized but feeling you belong to to
each one and these is a thing you can
talk about with blade that you can't
talk about with any other Marvel hero
really I think there's and there's
always the kind of disease slash drug
element to just vampirism I mean it's
all about [ __ ] blood and that's just
built into what that is it's it's a
metaphor for sex but I think that all of
those things getting to ride in a show
about [ __ ] killing vampires by a
vampire you know vamp on fam crime is
actually kind of heady and wonderful and
the fact that they don't have one yet
it's kind of boggling as for like deep
cut issues I was never like the deepest
blade reader so so I aside from finding
a real good way to do Deacon Frost
because the [ __ ] Steven whatever his
name was yes that versions door door
door yeah door phone Vance
not so cool but I think that that making
that character a for-real legit threat
and finding a way to talk about things
like like the the the attraction of the
vampire lifestyle like their you know
without anybody being sparkly and
without it being some weird [ __ ] like
may-december 2049 relation of a
relationship like I think you can you
can talk about the attractiveness of
that with a character like Deacon Frost
and how blade resists that at every turn
but it still kind of falling prey to all
of the jewels and gems of that world
it's kind of fun and then like just as
an aside like would like like while you
having all this wood wood blade sort of
like be sort of like that stick out
character like everybody knows or would
you sort of like follow this arc where
he's just coming up and it's like this
whole world is like it's ruled by the
vampires basically but you have this
this little like I'm trying to like kind
of like compared to this idea where it's
it's it's sort of like in the middle of
things the whole world's going to [ __ ]
but you have this one character that's
still kind of a part of that but at a
certain point kind of turns and goes
like yeah no I'm like against this like
how would you make that that turn I
guess I mean I definitely wouldn't do an
origin story because origin stories are
almost always the least interesting
version of that character I know how
that works but I think there's a way to
to do sort of a lucky Yojimbo thing
there right okay there's a way to have
blade kind of a drifter to a certain
degree like even still spoken of in
legend and happenstance and whatever but
he stumbles upon this particular
conflict between either these two
different vampire clans or a vampire
clan in the human clan and he's torn
between which one of them is right which
one is wrong not realizing or eventually
realizing that it's a symbiotic
relationship without one you can't have
the other and they both need to find a
way to harmonize and maybe blade
has to pay the ultimate price for
building that balance right now baby
joke about Netflix right now the like
Netflix what are we green lighting well
I just have one question for you mark
you talked about the parallel universes
in this in this series Castle Rock so
that really leaves me only one question
and that which of Stephen King's stories
took place in black Henry's universe and
which took place in white Henry's
universe oh damn you you split the
cannon down the center by introducing
two universes so that kind of throws the
question out there
well needful things took place in Henry
ones universe right cuz there's a clip
in the newspaper Dolores Claiborne took
place in white Henry's universe the
other one the other one although she
didn't kill her husband she opened up a
shop or both yeah I don't know
Kujo check please Kaku Jo is in this e
one yeah black energy I can reverse
right to it but do they confirm do you
feel like better handles like yes Roth
which universe is it dairies circled but
we don't know the balloons were in white
Henry's universe so I feel like that's
more of a Pennywise situation we have
going there I'm going to clear I mean
all of that sounds great
I believe all of it yeah I got no answer
to that I just don't like that wood we
had never really discussed like which
takes place in which because okay we
were never gonna fundamentally spend a
ton of time in the other universe
it's like grinding out which the
totality of that of that universe right
dead zone takes place in yes yeah you're
right yeah that's definitely exactly and
he killed himself and there's a hole she
sleeps like a baby because you wanted to
have a whole thing where we went like
one of the JJ calls was to get to see we
get Martin Sheen to come back and do
like a campaign ad as the president and
the only theory I have about why white
Henry is quote-unquote so evil I mean he
doesn't age in this universe because
time affects him differently I just
think it's the lingual ears trying to
catch up to him all right that just me
you [ __ ] win I don't have any more
tickets which would you like a beer
listen boys and girls ladies and
gentlemen have you had a good time
tonight I I would have been up here all
by my lonesome trying to make you people
[ __ ] laugh if it wasn't for law Ralph
Cornett who came to help me talk about
this thing that is so hard to talk about
so thank you raw before for devoting a
night out of your busy life out of your
post venom world
and talk about castle rock with me and
where can people find you on the on the
Internet
I'm at Roth cornet on the things I'm on
screen junkies and screen joke oh really
like honest trailers I don't make okay
but I know the people who do and it's
been an honor and a pleasure mark is
like he was your amazing the
aspirational story spire to more yeah we
know you've got a Netflix series it's
blade I don't you just wait I'm totally
looking happen you guys that is all that
we have tonight for the inaugural
episode of black man beyond I do not
know when Kevin is back in town so I do
not know when we're gonna do a full on
for real fat man beyond again but I'm
hoping before October's out cuz it would
be a shame to not do one of these before
Halloween we maybe will do a costume
contest Lando this deals getting worse
all the time
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen good night come
back next time Saint that time save
their channel SModcast calm Lord
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith command
everybody
[Applause]